where the river meets the ocean in
Senegal cine Saloon Delta lies the
village of bombardi hometown of a
football Giant sajomani
this is where it all started for him on
this pitch playing without boots or shin
guards money would skip school in
practice day and night hour after hour
determined to be faster stronger and
more agile constantly challenging
himself
hoping to follow in his footsteps is 13
year old nyali Gomez
I want to become like sadio Mane and
become a big player so that one day
people will watch me on TV and a full
Stadium will call my name
from bambali to Liverpool and on to
Munich money made history leading
Senegal to victory at the Africa Cup of
Nations but a recent injury to his knee
means he's not in Qatar with the Lions
of taranga
it's as if bumbali is in mourning
praying for money and for the national
team
his childhood friend is overwhelmed with
emotion
it's really painful to realize that a
style like sajomani will not play this
world cup it's a blow to the entire
nation he then addresses money
if you are listening I hope that God
protects and supports you you will heal
we are here for you
and he is here for them money has built
a hospital schools a fuel station he's
brought electricity to bombali and wants
to pave the roads at religious
celebrations he contributes to each
household
Sergio Monet is using his wealth to
change the lives of his people and while
he'll be absent for this world cup his
legacy goes beyond football
to what he does off the pitch and that's
an example that young people here want
to follow
no it's less the fame of football and
more the desire to give back that
motivates these young players and the
dream of one day representing their
country
together they chant for the national
team a traditional song used as a right
of passage don't be afraid they sing
there is nothing to lose move forward
Victory is to come
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera bambali Senegal